[Music]
what is your advice must have a lot of
young people that say beau how do I get
into the business how do I accomplish
what you've accomplished your advice for
young people I'd say well you gotta just
take a deep breath and give up don't
this system is rigged against you your
hard work and talent will not pay off
that's it good night everybody I would
say don't don't take advice from people
like me who've gotten very lucky you
know we're very by like Taylor Swift
telling you to follow your dreams is
like a lottery winner saying liquidize
your assets buy powerball tickets it
works you will get you just you won't
it's what I do agree with is I give up a
lot for luck I say I work really hard I
think I have some ability but I also got
really lucky and when some people act
like that's not part of it it makes me a
little crazy yeah of course and we're
tall white guys we overcame nothing to
be here there was nothing standing in
our way and we barely got here you have
no chance
what a fantastic message let's get that
out there and there's going to be like
little children singing later and they
have the light of God in their eyes and
they should be happy but once you get a
debit card you know give up okay
you